O kim
de
sosyal hayatımızda yaşıyor çevreniz
değişiyor Belki işi bırakıyorsunuz
alışkanlıklarınızı yaşıyor geceniz
gündüz yüzünü gündüzümüz birbirine
karışıyor ve çocukla bir süre içiçe
kaldığınızda
bir şekilde Asosyal yaşıyorsunuz ve bu
kabımıza çekiyorsunuz bir şekilde Assos
yerleşiyor Sun Çünkü sürekli çocukla
birlikte olmak zorundasınız ama
gündeminiz değişiyor sosyal medya daha
çok kullanmaya başlıyorsunuz sosyal
medyayı daha farklı kullanmaya
başlıyorsunuz Çünkü artık eskisi gibi
her an yanımızda bulabileceğimiz annemiz
teyzemiz Kardeşimiz çok yakın
dostlarımız yok birimizden çok uzak
yaşıyoruz Biz de eskiden üretken olan
çok eskiden üretken olan anneler
durduğumuz yerde duramadık ve önce
Blokları mıza başladık hemen ardından
sosyal medyayı başka bir biçimde aktif
kullanmaya başladık dediğim gibi gecenin
üçünde mesela Çocuğunuz ateşlendiğinde
dediğim gibi Yanınızda kimse olmuyor ama
Sweet attığınızda burada özellikle saat
2 ne demek istiyorum 4.00 20'de
derdinizi paylaştığınızda tweet atıp
hemen arkasından 4.00 24'te
Derdinize Derman olacak stresinizi
alabilecek başka bir anne orada online
oluyor Yine aynı şekilde saat 2.27 de
sabaha kadar Ateş dediğinizde 4.40 da
başka bir anne sesinizi ses oluyor ve
yalnız değilsin bir şekilde size
hissettirmiştir oluyor Evet mesela Benim
kendime ait bir Twitter hesabım vardı
fakat Anne olduktan sonra sırf şu
muhabbetlere dahil olabilmek için ayrı
bir hesap açtım Çünkü annelik hakkında
hiçbir şey bilmiyorum ama kendi listemde
sadece erkek arkadaşlarım var film ve
oyun konuşuyoruz başka bir şey
konuşmuyoruz
ya kendimize gizli bir hesap açtım iki
de çoluk çocuk orada Sırf bu muhabbeti
yapıyorum
Çünkü ben 24 saat internet başında
çalışan bir işim vardı fakat enteresan
bir geçiş yaptım ve çocukları bilgisayar
öğretmeye başladım orada Şunu fark ettim
siz bir işi ne kadar iyi biliyorsanız bu
karşınızdaki de ne kadar az biliyorsa
onu aktarmanız anlatmanız çok zorlaşıyor
bir çocuğa şimdi Mars'a al iki kere
ekrana tıkla dediğinizde Mouse alıp
ekrana vuruyor bunu
Evet ben de başa sardım yani
anlatabilmek için önce Mağusa elime
aldım Bakın bu bir fare fare
benzetiyoruz bunu İşte bunu da şunu
yapabiliriz falan diye çocuk gözünden
anlattığımda her şey yolunda oturdu
bunu her şekilde uygulayabileceğimiz de
fark ettik burada ben de eskiden
televizyon duydum ve son yaptığım
programda TRT şaşı teknoloji programı
yapmaktı Kürtçe teknoloji programı
yapmaktı ben tek kelime Kürtçe
bilmiyordum tek bizi teknolojiden de çok
anlamıyordum araştırıyordum
araştırıyordum teknoloji ile ilgili
konumuz Her neyse onu sadeleştir yordum
önce kendi anlayacağım hale getiriyordum
sonra Kürtçe'den editör arkadaşlara
veriyordum ve onlar onu çeviriyor bu
fakat beni Peki o zaman fark ettim ki
uygun sadeleştirilmiş de kullandığınızda
herkese her şeyi anlatabilirsiniz Yine
benzer bir biçimde sendikalı işçi
kadınları sosyal medya eğitimi verdik
orada da yine benzer biçimde yani konu
ne olursa olsun anlatabildiğim izi
gördük Şimdi hepinizin sanırım hak
vereceğinizi düşündüğüm bir durumla
karşılaştık biz uzakta kadın
arkadaşların kimi yargılar var ya
hepiniz bilirsiniz işte kadınlar araba
kullanmaktan çok anlamaz kadınlar Ofsayt
nedir bilmezler kadınlar şundan anlamaz
bundan anlamaz aslında ama bir sürü
farkettik ki tüm bu yargılar Aslında
kendini kanıtlayan
kehanetler Biz ne kadar bunu böyle
söylersek kadınlar Tabii ki de korkuyor
geri çekiliyor dalga geçirmekten endişe
ediyorlar ve sormuyorlar sormadık
larında da bilmiyor olmaya devam
ediyorlar ya da araba örneğinde olduğu
gibi panik diyorlar ve daha çok hata
yapıyorlar Bu bahsettiğim örnek gibi bir
durumla Biz Aslı bu ne kadar kolay
yapılabileceğini fark ettik
eğitimlerimizde şimdi hepiniz hosting
domain ile ilgili fikir sahibi sizlere
en azından duymuşsunuzdur Biz
eğitimlerimizde şöyle anlattık Gerçek
dünya ile sanal dünya aslında aynı siz
orada bir web sitesi yapmak
istediğinizde o bir ev gibi düşünün bir
arazi almamız gerekiyor işte o arazi
hosting Üstün evinizi yaptınız
birilerinin gelip sizi bulması için
oraya bir adres tabelası nız gerekiyor
işte bu da domain bu şekilde
anlattığımız da çevremizdeki anne
bloggerlarla demin bahsettiğim gibi
sendikalı işçi kadınlar Gayet net
biçimde hosting domain artık biliyor ve
unutmuyor hale gelmişlerdi bi ve biz
ipekle çeşitli anma etkinliklerine
tanışmıştık bu deneyimlerimizin
benzerliğini fark ettik bir aradayken
ikimizde teknolojiyi seviyorduk hiçbir
eğitimimizin olmamasına rağmen okuyup
edip kendini geliştirebiliyor duk ve
şimdi anlattığımız annemlerden kaynaklı
bunun anlatılabilir İliğini de görmüştük
bir gün oturduk Bir araya burada sürekli
çevremizden da ikimize geliyordu ondalık
yoksa nasıl yapacağız bir gün bir araya
geldik ve dedik ki bu kadar kolay
anlaşılabilir bir şey ise teknolojide
annelerin hayatını her açıdan bu kadar
kolaylaştıran bir şey ise eğer biz bir
site yapıp Bize gelen soruları
teknolojiyi faydalı nasıl
kullanabileceklerini dair her türlü
bilgiye ürünlerle ilgili annelerin
hayatını kolay kolaylaştıracak detayları
çocuklar için
King geliştirici oyunları anlatalım
yazalım ve Elimizden geldiği kadar çok
kişiyle ulaşalım İşte bu dediğimiz ano
andı Ondan sonra çalışmaya başladık Bir
web sitesi yaptık içeriğin oluşturduk ve
Ocak 2014'te de aktif olarak çalışmaya
başlıyoruz web sitesi hazırlamak
Wordpress tabanlı liste çok yani
hazırlamak kolay oluyor asıl önemli olan
içeriğin doldurmakta önce bir iki ay
içeri girdik sonra sitemizi açtık
çevremizden çok büyük destek gördü
kadınlarda özellikle İşte bu dedi o
çiçekten bize fakat şöyle birşey oldu
siteyi açtık çok güzel tepkiler alıyoruz
sorular geliyor fakat sorular hala İpek
ve Derya'ya geliyor Yani biz her türlü
sosyal medya hesabını açtık bana özelden
mesaj atılıyor Derya özelden mesaj
atılıyor Şunu fark ettim ki kadınlar
ortaya soru sormaktan çekiniyorlar Az
önce Derya'nın bahsettiği şeylerden olsa
gerek bizde bunu üzerine bir grup açtık
kapalı grup zaten Facebook grubumuz
vardı sayfamızda vardı ama bir de kapalı
grup açtık dedi ki gelin burada grupta
sadece kadınlar olarak herkes sorusunu
sorsun aramızdan kim gidiyorsa
cevaplasın
Ama anne bebek çocuk beslenme onları
buraya sokmayalım onunla ilgili çok grup
var zaten biz burada teknoloji
paylaşalım dedik Orada işler yoluna
girmeye başladı hatta çok enteresan bir
şey oldu bizi Facebook ara dışı
gerçekten Facebook'tan bir yetkili geldi
ve biz İstanbul'da bir beraber kahve
içtik çok güzel ki biz merak ediyoruz
Siz ne yapıyorsunuz yani siz bir grup
musunuz
bu
grup musunuz örgüt müsünüz kapalı grup
var bir şeyler var Bir anneler örgütü
var bir şey var dediler bir hikaye
bölümü anlattık
yakışmış şöyle bir durum var Biz
Amerika'da yazı Türkiye'de ofisimiz yok
ve oradan baktığımız zaman Türkiye'de şu
an böyle yasaklar engellemeler ve
saireler şu karmaşık Görünen bir ortam
var ve Kadınlara nasıl bakıldığını imajı
buradan çok farklı gözüküyor ve bizim
ortamımız da sizin bunu bizim Facebook'u
kullanıyor Tabii onlar Facebook
tarafından baktıkları için
kapalı bir grupta kadınlarla dijitali
dedikleri olmanız çok ilgimizi çekti ve
bunu
dünyadan ilkeler topluyoruz sizin
hikayenizde bu sene paylaşmak istediler
O heyecanla bekliyoruz bu arada
tam bunun üzerine bir de çok sevdiğim
Serdar kuzuloğlu Lan bir tweet geldi
teknolojiden anlamayan annelerin çocuğu
iletişim kurması artık imkansız buzları
eriten bir blokla tanıştırayım ve
bizdeki Tamam yani istediğimiz imajı
verebilmiş iz Çünkü tam olarak yapmak
istediğimiz buydu
işler yoluna girmişti Bunun arkasından
Bizim daha da çok yaygınlaştırma mıza
sebep olan bir şey oldu aslında
baktığınızda olumsuz bir şey dersiniz
hatırlarsanız geçen sene Türkiye'de
Twitter ve YouTube yasaklandı Biz o gece
şu yazı yazdık yasaklı Twitter'a nasıl
girilir
ama biz o yazı yazdık altta gördüğünüz
istatistik o zaman sanmayın bu da geçen
hafta yasaklamanın sayısı diyelim bizim
ortalama günlük 5000 olan trafiği miz
bir anda gördüğünüz gibi tak yaptı böyle
tekerrürden ibaret Evet ve ilginçtir ki
aralarına tam 1 yıl var bunun ardından
bize röportaj şekilde geldi yazılı
basından görsel basından burada çok
belli etme olabilir zaman ipekle ben de
aslında böyle sahnede olmayı çok
sevmeyen televizyon hoşlanmayan Mümkün
Mertebe az gerçekten hasta bulunmayı
seven insanlarız bir gün evde otururken
Ben telefon geldi Merhaba ben beyaz
soldan arıyorum bizim programına konuk
olurmusunuz dedi beni bir kelimem Eyvah
Oldu
oldu kadının anlattığı işte iki gün
sonra bekliyoruz falan diye tamam dedim
kapattım ipe yaradı mi pek beyaz Ozan
arıyorlar İki gün sonra katılmanız
istiyorlar dedim ipeğin ilk cümlesi
Eyvah oldu
bu ve biz böyle çevremizdeki eşimizin
dostumuzun ısrarları Hadi yaparız hadi
Barış ararsınız da gittikçe programı
katıldık programda Beyazıt dosttur bize
hani başınıza gelen İlginç komik Anılar
var mı diye sordu Ben de seni anlattım
onun iki gün öncesinde 1 Mayıs'ı 1
Mayıs'a da biliyorsun sokaklarda ayet
karışıktı Ben de sokaktayım babam bana
telefonla ulaşamayınca Twitter yeni
kullanmaya başlamıştı bir tweet attı
Kızım nasılsın İnfak at bunu mevsim
yapmadan ortaya tweet olarak attı
İyi ki bunu anlattım ya orada bütün sütü
diyor sizin gibi güldü Beyazıt Öztürk
Art
Beyazıt Öztürk'ün tepkisi bakın nasıldı
babanız da aynı durumdayım yani
ışınlamak ne ya bu
burada şunun altını çizmek istiyoruz bu
örnekteki iki özleminde cinsiyetine
dikkat çekiyoruz
bizi bu çok dikkat ettiğimiz bir şey Biz
Mümkün Mertebe ve hatta hiç kadınlarla
ilgili her yerde Bize soruyor Biz
anlatmıyorum Çünkü zaten dediğimiz gibi
kadınlar bu dalga geçmeler gülmeler
vesaire yüzünden geride durmayı tercih
ediyor O yüzden çok gerekirse şimdi oldu
gibi erkek hikayelerini anlatıyoruz
burada çevrede biz bu teknolojik anneler
olarak dolanmaya başlayınca Herkes bizim
her şeyi bildiğimizi sanıp her şey bize
sormaya başladı iki gün önce Adana'da
Yaşadığımız bir diyalog şu bir anne bana
dedi ki ya Derya sen biliyorsundur
fotoğraf mi kim
ya
ben de dedim ki yani Hiçbir fikrim yok
bilmiyorum Sen nasıl teknoloji Ben de
senden ne haber bu
Biz hakikaten birçok şey bilmiyoruz
bilmeye ve yaymaya çalışıyoruz öğrenmeye
çalışıyoruz kendimizi geliştirmeye
çalışıyoruz sürekli seminerlere
katılıyoruz bütün lansmanlara gidiyoruz
gittiğimiz lansmanlarda yüzlerce
teknoblog oluyor orada bütün basın
oluyor ama biz o ürünleri onlarla
birlikte Dinliyoruz ama asla böyle
kokufest yapıyoruz anne gözüyle de ben
işte ikimiz var aynı gözüyle paylaşırız
o telefona atınca kırılır mı İşte
kaç saat ben o telefonla video
çekebilirim ya da işte bir televizyonun
camı çizilirmi bir çocuk çizebilir miyim
Anne gözüyle bakıp olayları yaklaşıyoruz
ve yazdığımız tüm konular rı her türlü
sosyal medya hesabından paylaşıyoruz
burada gördüm Sen çok daha fazlası var
aslında fakat konuların hepsi çok
eğlenceli değil Bu ev çok sıkıcı
konularda var işte kombi nasıl
kullanılır işte lastiğinizi arabanın
şapka falan öyle şeyleri de her konuya
giriyoruz ama hesaplarımıza kadar sıkıcı
değil Mesela hesaplarımdan fotoğraf
görebilirsiniz
savaşta annelere Sosyal Hizmetler
Ama bunun mesajını merak ediyor musunuz
YouTube hesabı açmak ve YouTube kanalı
açmak çok sorular ve Kafa karışıyor
fotoğrafları ikisi var mı yok ama
YouTube logosuna çok daha keyifli oturdu
varsayıyoruz Ve biz bu daha kadar sıkıcı
konuları eğlenceli fotoğraflar koymaya
Başla ben yorumlar
Örneğin
yazıyor okuyamadım ve yazamadım
altına yazarsan yaz okurum var benim en
sevdiğim fotoğrafları gitsin diye sonuna
kadar yazıyı okuyanlar var ve artık biz
buna bir DH bu bilgi de anneler diyoruz
Ultra sıkıcı konulara bu tarz şu an Eğer
bakarsanız şöyle
dursun
her zaman böyle değil yani anneler
gitmek zorunda
Biz yaptığımız için çok severek
yapıyoruz çok eğlenerek yapıyoruz ve
gerçekten çok önemli olduğunu
düşünüyoruz biz yola çıkarken
ben hani hem kendimize hem de
ulaşabildiğimiz her kadına faydalı
olmayı hedefledik Ve bunu yaparken de
hani düşünmedik Bu fikir iyi ve yapmak
lazım dedik yaptık burada Hepiniz de
bizim tek tavsiyemiz su olabilir
herhangi bir fikriniz olduğunda Olur mu
olmaz mı diye düşünmeyin ve yola çıkın
zaten 17 fikir sebepsiz onu severek
yapıyorsanız mutlaka ilerle mutlaka bir
yere gidiyor biz bir sene boyunca kendi
imkanlarımızla eğitimler yapmaya
çalıştık Anneleri çağırdık ve sosyal
medya nasıl kullanılır den tutunda
internet güvenliğine kadar çocuğunuza
n3d internet kullandırma sızlık bu
eğitimler yaptık o esnada duymuşsunuzdur
Turkish bin sevgili meleğimiz Melek'le
irtibata geçtik ve onun da aracılığıyla
birçok güzel adım attık iki gün önce
adana'daydı kadındaki kadınlara anlattık
internet internet güvenliği sosyal medya
bundan sonra da aynı şekilde devam
edeceğiz önümüzde başka şehirlerde var
Biz duracağı duracağımız düşünmüyoruz
başka bir sürü fikrimiz de var ve
elimizden geldiğince ilerleyeceğiz bunu
yapacağımızı da emin Özgün'ün şarjınız
asla bitmez
izlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederiz
teşekkür o